après les toutes dernières informations
intéressons nous maintenant à
l'atmosphère qui depuis 48 heures règne
dans la capitale chinoise et dans sa
région c'est ce qu'ont fait nos envoyés
spéciaux georges bortoli et christian
lyon c'était la dernière nuit de liberté
à pékin la nuit de vendredi à samedi
deux cent mille étudiants regroupés
place tiananmen autour de leurs 3000
camarades grévistes de la faim avait
entendu un premier ministre li peng
annoncé des mesures de force pour mettre
fin aux manifestations
il savait le plusieurs colonnes
militaire convergeaient sur pékin alors
à 3 heures du matin la consigne est
tombée des haut parleurs que la
population se porte en masse en face des
soldats pour bloquer leur avance et ce
matin à l'aube les faubourgs de pékin
offrait à spectacle étonnant des
colonnes militaire bloqués par des
camions des autobus se bloque et surtout
par des grappes humaines par des masses
d'habitants des ouvriers surtout qui se
sont portés à leur rencontre pour
paralyser leur avance bien sûr d'abord
et aussi pour persuader les soldats leur
apprendre ce qu'est le mouvement pour la
démocratie
ces soldats ne savent rien ils viennent
de la très lointaine province du sichuan
où ils n'ont jamais entendu parler des
manifestations plus loin dans une
atmosphère déjà presque campagnarde
une autre colonne s'est garé loin de la
grande route
les soldats apparemment sans armes sont
confrontés à une véritable offensive de
la propagande estudiantine puisque des
étudiants juché sur un camion avec un
haut-parleur les ont rejoints les
harangues démocratie liberté
modernisation de la chine l'accueil est
plutôt sympathique pour un peu les
soldats les officiers même fraternisent
ray avec les porte parole des étudiants
ce samedi matin le mouvement des
véhicules d'heure épaulé par une immense
vague de sympathie de la population a pu
voir quelques instants qu'il avait gagné
la partie
quelques heures plus tard la situation a
bien changé les étudiants savent que les
chars ne sont pas à plus d'un kilomètre
de la place tienanmen et pourtant ils
sont là 400 milles au point sur la place
et leur détermination n'a pas faibli
elle est toujours aussi grande et c'est
ça qui frappe dans ce mouvement
ce mouvement étudiant il est très souple
il est trés non violent pour dire le
mans mais il montre une détermination
absolument sûre d'elle-même la
détermination d'introduire la démocratie
dans le système politique chinois